Hi! This segment is focused on the /ɔɪ/ sound.
/ɔɪ/ is a diphthong sound, and remember a diphthong is two vowel sounds that blend together so they almost feel like one.
Notice the movement in my tongue. /ɔɪ/, /ɔɪ/.
The tip of the tongue is relaxed and touching behind the lower front teeth for all vowel and diphthong sounds.
To make the /ɔɪ/ sound, you need to start by releasing your jaw.
Release the back of your tongue and bring the lip corners slightly forward like this, /ɔ/.
And then, move the front of the tongue up toward the gum ridge to the /ɪ/ position.
The second part of the diphthong is always shorter than the first, but you must make both sounds.
We'll start slowly and then we'll blend them to a normal pace.
/ɔɪ/, /ɔɪ/, /ɔɪ/, /ɔɪ/, /ɔɪ/, /ɔɪ/, /ɔɪ/.
A common challenge with the /ɔɪ/ sound is that the speaker will neglect the second part of the diphthong.
This results in the /ɔɪ/ sounding like /oʊ/.
So let's practice each of the two sounds in the diphthong, separately and then together.
Drop your jaw and the back of your tongue and bring your lip corners forward /ɔ/, /ɔ/, /ɔ/.
Now, let's try the /ɪ/ sound. Match your sound with mine /ɪ/, /ɪ/, /ɪ/.
Now, let's put them together. /ɔɪ/, /ɔɪ/, /ɔɪ/, /ɔɪ/, /ɔɪ/.
Now, let's compare /ɔɪ/  with /oʊ/.
Feel the difference between the two sounds as we try them together.
She sold the soiled clothes.
Most cookies are moist.
That cold snake coiled up.
Keep practicing on EnglishCentral and good luck!